>>Teacher: We're in a mandatory
evacuation situation now.
You're looking at anywhere
from 10 to 14,
15 feet of storm surge, parish wide.
>>Narrator: A hurricane is
bearing down on New Orleans.
>>Student: Okay, right now I'm
going to need the fire department.
>>Narrator: And eighth graders from
Landry Middle School, have assembled
at the nearby emergency response
center to deal with the mock crisis.
>>Student: Do we deliver babies?
>>Student: We're going to try.
>>Student: How are we going to
get the paramedic to her house?
>>Student: We're going
to send two paramedics.
>>Narrator: Power is
out, bridges are down,
and a pregnant woman
is calling for help.
The situation demands clear
judgment, teamwork and improvisation.
>>Student: Two minutes apart,
that baby is coming out.
>>Student: So we have any
type of transportation?
>>Girl: Don't we have--
oh, the truck, you know,
the drive through water--
>>Student: It's like a Hummer.
>>Student: So we're
going to use that truck
to bring the paramedics to her house.
>>Dianne: Anytime we teach and we use
real relevant real life experiences,
kids are immersed in those
experiences and learning is fun.
And the bottom line is when learning
is fun, it's easy and it comes quick
to the kids, and they enjoy it.
>>Narrator: After some anxious
moments, the storm passes,
and science teacher Linda
Watsky quizzes her class
on what they've gained
from the exercise.
>>Student: I will always
remember the stress.
I mean, it's hard being Parish
President, you've got people, like,
you know, Christie over here,
well you've got a fire over here,
and let's say, Teneesha over
here, a tree fell down over here.
And I'm, okay, well all
right, okay, well then, okay,
then I'm going to do this.
All right, and then it's stressful.
I mean, you've got to listen
to so many things at one time.
>>Linda: Okay, how does what we were
learning in class, relate to this?
What does it take to solve a problem?
Do you always have to be
right the first go round?
>>All: No.
>>Linda: Okay, so the same
with, in scientific method.
The difference in class is you're
solving it to learn knowledge.
In here, you're solving it to save
people's lives, and I think that's
where the stress comes in.
>>Teacher: The back of your
car has to be on this line.
>>Narrator: Not all of Landry's
class work is stressful.
>>Teacher: If you hold it
just there for your partner.
>>Narrator: In fact,
much of the hands
on project based learning
here is downright fun.
>>Teacher: Okay?
>>Narrator: To engage their
students at the end of the year,
the eighth grade teachers came up
with a project focusing on cars.
In science class, students
made balloon propelled cars
out of recycled materials, and
road tested their various designs.
>>Teacher: Oh, it curved,
look at that.
>>Narrator: Like most Landry
projects, the car unit was featured
across the eighth grade curriculum.
>>Teacher: Try to write some
different selling points.
>>Narrator: In language arts,
students wrote car commercials,
and in math, they calculated
loan payments.
>>Teacher: At six percent,
of whatever you get
for item number seven.
>>Student: So multiply six percent--
>>Teacher: Percent times that.
>>Student: Okay.
>>Narrator: They also used the web
to plan trips and find information
on fuel economy and
environmental impacts.
>>Student: Not only is the
vehicle going to save the earth,
it also comes with
most standard features
that all consumers
really, really like.
>>Narrator: And they evaluated
pitches from local car salesmen.
>>Salesman: Here you can see, this
truck, at least, it's fully equipped,
it has cruise control, the tilt
steering wheel, it has power windows
and power door locks,
and power mirrors.
>>Student: How much does it
take to fill up the tank?
How much it costs?
>>Salesman: And that's
going to be close
to 40 dollars for, you
know, an empty tank.
>>Teacher: In the math thing,
they were very much into it.
We talked about--
>>Narrator: The eighth grade
teachers coordinate their efforts
and evaluate the progress of
projects during their daily 45 minute
shared time.
>>Teacher: And we had little
scenarios where they reached
in the bag and pulled out
whether they're single
or whether they have three kids,
so when they went to pick the cars,
it was like, you know, I
want this car that's 147,000,
but my income on my
profile card says,
all I'm making is 48,000 dollars, but
I have to take care of three kids.
>>Narrator: For these teachers,
the benefits of team teaching extend
beyond curriculum development.
>>Dianne: One of the
things that the kids say,
is they see that we work as a team.
Plus that's also the way the
business world is run, in teams.
So what we expect them to be
able to do, as young adults,
that is what we practice here,
so that they can see the
real world connection.
>>Student: The downpayment
you gave was 1,000,
so more or less what you have is 48.
So this is how much you
wanted to pay, but--
>>Narrator: At Landry,
students practice teamwork, too.
>>Student: Are you lost?
Are you getting me?
>>Student: I got you.
>>Student: You got me?
So what happens is, you
have to pay the bank back.
>>Narrator: Students of varying
abilities are grouped in teams
of four, which often include
older students needing extra help.
>>Jont'e: We don't
really work by ourselves.
Because we sit in groups, and
if we have a question, well,
if we don't know it, then we ask,
like, our peers and our pupils,
and if they don't know it,
then we ask the teacher,
because it's really like a community.
We stay-- we're one big family,
and we are the Landry family
and we help each other out.
>>Linda: I've had kids come
back to me and tell me,
"Do you remember that
project we did?"
They have never, ever come back and
said, "Remember that test we did?"
So I think that's the impact.
If the kids remember, test scores
will go up, and our test scores have.
>>Student: We need
two and two, because--
>>Mentor: I know another
Y. I'm doing Ys over one.
>>Narrator: Volunteer mentors
from local industry are also
part of the Landry family.
>>Paul: We come here once a week, and
we get the satisfaction of working
with excellent students
and seeing the future.
>>Narrator: And when
new technology is thrown
into the mix, learning is a blast.
>>Teacher: Out.
Go back, same way, in
and out, in and out.
>>Paul: We're doing a study
of motion and graphing.
We're letting the students
see that, as they walk,
this motion detector here, graphs
their path, and we're going
to show them that their walk
can be interpreted into math.
>>Teacher: You see it?
Where's that gap?
The gap is way up there,
you know why?
What is it reading?
>>Student: Nothing.
>>Teacher: It read
nothing, it read the wall.
So we--
>>Narrator: While students,
teachers and community members work
in teams throughout the year, the
ultimate test of teamwork at Landry,
comes when a group of traveling
circus professionals arrives.
[Cheering]
>>Narrator: Known as
Circus of the Kids,
they spend two weeks turning ordinary
students into high flying acrobats
and accomplished performers
who delight
and terrify an audience
of peers and parents.
>>Vanessa: It raises their self
esteem, lets them know that,
as long as you try, you know, at
anything, you can do your best.
You just have to be positive.
It's kind of dangerous, but if
they teach them well, actually,
yeah, he was a fire eater.
So I just was glad when it was over.
>>Student: And now for your
entertainment our jugglers, Amanda--
>>Student: At first when I heard
about it, I was like, circus,
you know, I can't do this,
I'm not even going to try.
But when they started showing me
how to do this, they demonstrated it
for us, and it was like,
okay, well maybe I can do it.
And I started doing it, and realized,
I'm really good at this stuff
[Cheering]
>>Narrator: For more information on,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.